[Music]
with Thor's new hammer being confirmed
to be storm breaker in Avengers infinity
war I thought to do a video on its
origins in the comics and its powers
that it has before we get started please
be sure to hit that subscribe button to
show some love and stay up to date with
Avengers infinity war it's interesting
to compare the comics to the MCU
because in the comics the hammer isn't
actually made for Thor in the comics the
hammer is commissioned by Odin himself
to be made for a cybernetic korbinite
beta ray bill hear the story of beta ray
bill is actually pretty interesting for
those of you who don't know it
shield discovers an unidentified ship
heading to earth and they send Thor to
check it out once Thor arrives at the
ship which is called the scuttlebutt
it's scans Thor and perceives him as a
threat in which it sends beta ray bill
out to fight him much to everyone's
surprise beta ray bill was actually just
a strongest door at the two of them
fighting to a standstill
but it was an even bigger surprise when
beta ray bill went to pick up Thor's
hammer Mjolnir and was actually worthy
enough to pick it up this led to Odin
teleporting beta ray bill and Thor back
to Asgard
once Odin discovered that bill was
worthy enough to lift me all near he
proposed a battle to the death between
bill and Thor on the fiery Asgardian
realm of scar theme the battle ends in
somewhat of a draw both knocking each
other out unconscious at the same time
but due to build cybernetic enhancements
he was able to wake from unconsciousness
first bill had the opportunity to kill
Thor but seeing him a worthy adversary
actually saved his life and brought him
back to Asgard upon returning to Asgard
and speaking with Odin bill demanded
that he keep mule near scene as he won
the battle and could use it to defend
his almost extinct race instead of
giving bill mule near he ordered a new
hammer to be made by the same dwarf star
Nadav Alire thus bringing into the world
storm breaker
so this storyline from the comics is
clearly not how Thor is going to get
Stormbreaker in Avengers infinity war
although we did see an easter egg of
beta ray bill and thor ragnarok it is
very unlikely that he is going to make
an appearance and Avengers infinity war
but since we did in fact get that easter
egg in thor ragnarok this does confirm
that he exists in the MCU so we're left
with a question how does Thor get
Stormbreaker
and Avengers infinity war although we
can't really answer this question
because well we haven't seen the movie
yet it's clearly obvious from the
trailers that we've received that Thor
teen Groot and Rocket go on a mission to
get a hammer for Thor it's actually kind
of apparent from the trailers that Thor
it will be forging Stormbreaker himself
this would mean that Stormbreaker
doesn't exist in the MCU yet and he's
never met beta ray bill but it does
leave it open for future Thor movies if
we look at the leaked photo of the toy
that was released of Stormbreaker that
actually confirmed it for us there's an
aspect of Stormbreaker in the MCU that
doesn't exist in the comics and that is
the handle if we look again at the
picture of the toy we can see that the
handle is actually made of what looks
like branches and it's widely believed
that the branches come from team Groot
this would make sense because it's
rumored that Thor and teen group become
very close in infinity war it does
however leave the question why doesn't
Thor just forge a handle maybe he gets
the Nadav allure and there's not much
arrow metal left and he only has enough
to make the head of it we're not sure
why but I actually have a theory of my
own in the comics beta ray bill is there
when the dwarves of the dollar form
Stormbreaker
they tell him to reach into the furnace
wearing a gauntlet and grab Stormbreaker
as it's being made and pull it out since
in the trailers we see that wherever
they're forging this new hammer is
pretty much deserted maybe there's not a
gauntlet for Thor to wear to keep him
from getting burnt in the furnace
we know that teen rout can grow his
branches whenever he wants so maybe he
volunteers to reach into the furnace and
in turn his branches fused with the head
of Stormbreaker this however is just a
personal theory and I'm very curious to
see what happens in the movies so having
talked about its origins and where it
came from in the comics and how four
might get it in infinity war I want to
talk about its abilities as I mentioned
before Odin ordered the hammer to be
made by the doors of Nadav lair who are
the same dwarves that made mule near
storm breakers actually made of the same
Earl metal that mule NER is made out of
as well but the hammers aren't equal in
strength actually Stormbreaker is more
powerful than mule near this is because
Odin himself actually puts an
enchantment on Stormbreaker the
enchantment gives Stormbreaker the
abilities that Mueller has such as the
worthiness enchantment meaning only the
worthy can lift it the ability to throw
it in it being able to return to
cinder and of course it's simply just
having amazing striking power but it
also has new abilities that mule NIR
doesn't have such as the power of
teleportation
this gives the wielder the ability to
transport inter-dimensionally or to
teleport objects
it also has elemental control it not
only has the ability to summon lightning
but it also has the ability to create
storms and tints gale force winds and
rain and last but not least it has
energy projection different from
lightning but is a powerful concussive
type blast as well composed of some type
of mystical energy it seems appropriate
that Thor will be getting storm breaker
and Avengers infinity war scene as it is
much stronger than mule NIR and Thanos
is going to be the toughest villain that
Thor or the Avengers have ever faced
what do you think about Thor's new
hammer Stormbreaker do you prefer it or
do you prefer his original hammer
Mjolnir also what do you think about
beta ray bill being in the MCU let me
know in the comments below and please be
sure to drop a like and subscribe to my
channel to stay up-to-date on Avengers
infinity war Thor all things Marvel and
all things superhero thank you so much
for watching
woof woof